i want to jump into the whole placebo
effect for a little bit here
and basically um talk about the
implications of that
if i give you a sugar pill and i tell
you it's a sugar pill
you won't get any better but if i tell
you sugar pill and tell you and
i tell you wow this is an amazing drug
it actually will stop your cancer
your cash will actually stop with much
higher
probability what does that mean that's
so amazing that means that if i can
trick your brain
into thinking that i'm healing you your
brain will basically figure out a way to
heal itself to heal the body
and that tells us that there's so much
that we don't understand
in the interplay between our cognition
and our biology that if we were able to
better harvest
the power of our brain to sort of you
know
impact the body through the placebo
effect we would be
so much better in so many different
things just by tricking yourself into
thinking that you're doing better you're
actually doing better
so there's something to be said about
sort of positive thinking about optimism
about sort of
you know just getting your
brain and your mind into the right
mindset
that helps your body and helps your
entire biology
yeah from a science perspective that's
just fascinating i
obviously most things about the brain is
a total mystery for now
but that's a fascinating interplay that
the brain
yeah that the brain can reduce
uh the brain can help cure cancer as uh
i don't even know what to do with that i
mean the way to think about that is the
following
the converse of the equation is
something that we are much more
comfortable with
like oh if you're stressed then
your heart right might rise and all
kinds of sort of toxins might be
released and
that can have a detrimental effect in
your body etc
so maybe it's easier to understand your
body
healing from your mind by your mind is
not killing your body
or at least it's killing it less so i
think the you know
that aspect of the stress equation is a
little easier
for most of us to conceptualize but then
the healing part
is you know perhaps the same pathways
perhaps different pathways but again
something that
is totally untapped scientifically
you